NEED A WIN TONIGHT.
>> Dave:
SEASON.
BACK TO STAMKOS D THEN FABBRO
GOES HE'S A LITTLE FASTER  JOHA
CIRELLI, HE SHOOTS, SCORES .THE
BACK.
THE TURNOVER ALLOWS CIRELLI TO
GET IN BEHIND HIM, AND IT IS
GOOD TO SEE A PAYOFF ON A
REALLY GOOD GOAL.
THAT WILL BE A CONFIDENCE
BU
THERE.
JOHANSEN,  BACK QUICK PASS ACRO
DROP HANGS ONTO IT, SHOOTS, AND
THIS.
STILL PRETTY PASSING.    UP.
TRENIN WITH D IT
WAS SLOPPY, AND THEN  CIRELLI
GETS BEATEN IN THE NEUTRAL McDO
OUT IN FRONT,
THAT IS S L . FIRES THAT
WIDE.
AND NOW HE'S AT FORT.
DOES A TERRIFIC   PASS ACROSS,
HE JUST PLAYS IN , ANOTHER DROP
PALAT.
HERE'S STAMKOS . IN FRONT WITH
E KIND OF
STUFF THAT SAROS HAS BEEN DOING
ALL SEASON LONG, WHICH IS WHY
DEFENSEMAN.
CARRIER,  DID THIS GO OFF OF
HIS HIP?
I'M NOT SURE, FIRST TIME TONIGH
THAT PASS TRYING TO GET THE
CIRELLI SKATES IT AWAY, PUTS IT
BACK ACROSS , BACK HE ADJUSTMENO